hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
a lot of you guys were asking for this
video
so here it is as you guys know we've
been testing apple's new m1 max
for about three weeks now and it's clear
that apple is
totally revolutionizing the computer
industry
by giving us incredible performance
while getting
even more impressive battery life than
we expected
for example we compared the m1 macbook
pro to the base
16-inch intel model and when the 16-inch
went down to 3
of battery life remaining the m1 was at
a staggering
67 battery life we then compared the m1
mac mini
to our thousand five hundred and fifty
dollar imac
and the most impressive part was the
performance per watt
being over six times higher on the m1
cpu
and over nine times higher in terms of
the graphics
results like this are extremely exciting
because we know that apple's going to be
transitioning the rest of their mac
lineup
over to their own m series of chips
and that's exactly what this video is
all about
yes i'm talking about the apple m1x chip
which is rumored to be going into next
year's higher end max
like the 16 inch macbook pro now i'm not
only going to be discussing the
performance and features that we should
expect to go into the m1x
but i'm also going to talk about which
other max
this chip is going to be going into and
how
those macs should be getting fully
redesigned as well
so let's get right into it way back in
april before apple even announced the
transition to their own silicon
it was reported that apple's first arm
chip would be a 12
core 5 nanometer soc but that
obviously didn't happen since the m1
chip has a total of eight
cores including four efficiency cores
and four high performance cores and now
it's pretty clear that the 12 core chip
that they were reporting on
is still actually coming next year in
the form of the m1x chip
or at least that's the most probable
name for it
since the m2 chip won't be coming out
until
a full year after the release of the m1
now this matches up to recent rumors of
two redesigned macbook pros coming in
2021 more specifically the 14 inch
and 16 inch models and of course there
are also
rumors of a redesigned 24 inch imac
coming early next year as well and i'm
going to be talking about all of that in
just a couple of minutes
now getting back to next year's m1x chip
it'll be packed with the same four
efficiency cores
but it'll come with double the
performance cores
eight instead of four and keep in mind
that the cores themselves
will stay essentially the same so the
single core performance
shouldn't change much at all compared to
the m1
however the multi-core performance is
going to drastically
improve because of the extra 4
performance cores
so we should expect a score of around 12
000 points in geekbench 5's multi-core
test
essentially outperforming the current
12 core mac pro which is absolutely
insane
on top of that we should definitely
expect apple to include
more graphics cores in the m1x as well
but i'm not sure if it's going to come
with 12 or 16
of those gpu cores but if we do get 16
gpu cores that would be insane because
it'll give us around
44 000 metal score and geekbench
5 which is more graphics performance
than
the crazy powerful and expensive 5600m
dedicated gpu and the current 16-inch
macbook pro
now one thing we could see is apple
selling two versions
of the m1x they could sell the base
model
with a 12 core gpu and give you the
option to upgrade to
a 16 core gpu for a couple hundred
dollars more
to do this apple would use silicon
binning to disable the gpu cores that
didn't meet
quality standards and then they would
market that
chip as having a 12 core gpu for a lower
price
meant for the base models instead of
just tossing that chip out altogether
if you think about it apple already did
this with the m1 macbook air
the base model comes with a silicon bin
7
core gpu and you have the option to
upgrade
to an 8 core so apple could be doing
this again
with the m1x now as far as the features
i
fully expect the m1x to support four
thunderbolt ports
just like we currently have on the
higher end 13-inch
and 16-inch macbook pro models compared
to the m1 chip
which seems to be bandwidth limited only
supporting
two of those ports that reason alone is
why apple kept selling
the high-end intel 13-inch macbook pro
as well as the intel mac mini instead of
moving everything over to apple silicon
the answer to that is of course the m1x
chip
which will support four ports and it
will support
10 gigabit ethernet on the mac mini if
and when apple chooses to add the m1x
chip
as an upgrade for the mac mini i also
believe that the m1x will come with 16
gigs of ram at the base price
with the potential to upgrade to at
least 32 gigabytes of ram
which is currently the limit for the
high-end intel 13-inch macbook pro
now with all of that out of the way i
want to get into exactly which
macs are going to be coming with the new
m1x chip
and this brings us to some recently
released rumors
the apple analyst micciaquo says that
redesigned 14.1
and 16.1 inch macbook pros will be
released
during the first half of 2021
both of them coming with mini led
displays
and apple silicon chips now in my
personal opinion
those displays are gonna come with
rounded corners
just like you get with both the ipad air
4 and
the ipad pro and i know this because the
windows on mac os big sur
are now rounded much more than they were
before
on top of that these mini led displays
will be much
thinner than previous displays which
will allow
apple to finally upgrade the webcam to a
1080p
sensor now other than that i don't
really know what else to expect from
these redesigned macbooks
except potentially an even thinner
chassis
due to the space savings from switching
to apple silicon
now as far as the prices i expect the
new 14 inch macbook pro
to stick to the same eighteen hundred
dollar base price
as well as the same twenty four hundred
dollars for the new
16 inch macbook pro now there's only one
doubt that i have
there's a chance that the 14 inch
macbook pro will actually come with an
m1 chip at the base price instead of the
m1x
and apple could find a way to just get
an extra two ports on that model
potentially adding another i o chip
externally
in that case apple could easily add the
m1x
as an upgrade option but i'm really
hoping
that the base model will come with the
m1x chip
giving it an exceptional value now on
top of that
mingchaquo also mentioned that a new
macbook air is expected in
2022 so apple could be skipping a full
year
before upgrading it again now moving on
to the imax
we already know that a fully redesigned
24 inch imac
is expected as soon as the first quarter
of next year
so here's how i think the imac release
will happen
if the 24 inch imac is released before
the m1x macbooks
then i fully expect that mac to simply
come
with the regular m1 chip since the
starting price of the current 21.5 inch
imac
is only 1100 which is perfect for the m1
now if apple decides to release this new
24 inch imac
at the same time or after the macbooks
then we should expect it to get the m1
chip
at the base price with an added upgrade
option
to get the m1x with 16 gigs of ram and
a 512 gig ssd but on the other hand
apple could be saving the m1x for the
27-inch imac replacement
which could come with the larger display
size between
30 and 32 inches and according to china
times
that larger imac should be launching in
the second half
of next year but with a major twist
apple is working on a custom dedicated
gpu
for that imac which is going to greatly
boost the graphics performance
and it's going to be our first taste of
an apple silicon
dedicated graphics chip which will be
extremely exciting to see
since the performance per watt of the m1
ship
is absolutely insane and of course this
custom gpu technology
will be improved upon even more to
eventually go
into apple's mac pro with apple silicon
which in my opinion won't be coming out
until sometime
in 2022 but we're just gonna have to
wait and see
so there you guys go let me know if you
agree with my thoughts on
apple's roadmap for the future custom
silicon max
down in the comments section below and
if you agree with my estimates
for the m1x's performance click that
circle above to subscribe
and definitely check out those m1 mac
videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video